hey it's Ke$ha
I just got an iPad today I know iPad
I've had three called the iPad 3 3 3 G I
got it
so when I'm on tour and when I'm singing
and I'm done and I was just so I can
just have like this you have something
it's cool it's cool
mostly cuz my song the one song party at
a rich dudes house I wrote with that
song about the guy that makes these
things Steven why didn't you call me I
thought I would call me but he never
never called just school cuz it doesn't
matter I don't need that thing that cuz
I got this iPad now just you just get a
drink in it I got my iPad I can just can
you do you smoke this thing I guess no I
can't
if you could would be so cool yeah I buy
my album and look for many music video
it's coming out soon